an outrageous decision out of the US
Supreme Court today by a five to four
vote the High Court ruled against the
Trump administration's efforts to end
daca Obama's unilateral program that
gave legal protections to immigrants
brought to the country illegally as
children and just like in the case of
Obamacare was Chief Justice John Roberts
joining the four liberals on the court
to make a highly technical ridiculous to
me argument that benefited the Obama
administration now even Barack Obama
himself recognized he can't do this by
executive Fiat but he did it anyway
before rolling out daca in 2012 Obama
said he needed an act of Congress to
help the so-called dreamers watch it
watch this clip of him addressing
immigration activists in 2011 now I know
some people want me to bypass Congress
and change the laws on my own the idea
of doing things on my own is very
tempting I promise you not not not just
not just on immigration reform
[Applause]
but that's not how that's not how our
system works that's that's that's not
how our democracy functions Democratic
Republic here was reaction acting DHS
secretary Chad Wolfe Chad his admit he
didn't have the power to do it he did it
anyway John Roberts did this with health
care maybe he wants to a different job
title in his life because it's certainly
not following the law by any reasonable
expectation any reasonable analysis that
I see well Shawn what I can tell you is
that the daca program is clearly
unlawful and even the supreme court
today in their opinion said that the
Department of Homeland Security has the
authority to rescind it they simply
didn't like the way that we were doing
it and I think that's troubling to me
because what we saw under the Obama
administration what you a clip that you
just played is they made this program
out of thin air did it on a turn of a
dime this administration has thought
long about this thoughtful about this
decided to wind this unlawful program
down over a series of six months and
again what we have is a Supreme Court
saying that's not good enough you need
to go back at it you need to relook at
that and that's very troubling to me
yeah well and and he himself admitted
Obama that he couldn't do it but then he
did it anyway
so is it cut was it constitutional
because I don't believe it was that's
absolutely right so we have one
administration making a program we have
a second administration another
administration taking a look at how do
we wind down an unlawful program what
the other what the Obama administration
did is create a new law a new visa or
new program a deferred action program
out of thin air Congress is the right
role to do this we have been begging
Congress to address the daca recipients
they have decided not to do this time
and time again the president has been
clear on this he wants a legal solution
and not a political solution to this
issue very disappointed in the decision
today but we'll keep at it
president will have 400 miles a new wall
by election day there about secretary
thank you